hey guys it's Justine and surprise this
title of this video is actually not
clickbait for once come on I'm actually
that bad of a click Vader
you know there's far worse at least when
I click bait you sometimes I'm nice
enough to at least put in the
description at what time code I'm
actually talking about said thing last
year I titled several videos new hair
and I knew this because I downloaded all
of my 2016 videos to create Shay 24-hour
compilation video of all of my 2016
videos which is coming soon there's been
a lot of complications I've decided to
try to do something a little bit
different with my hair but you know I
say that every single time and usually I
get scared and I go back to what I'm
comfortable with
this is Gabi she's been doing my hair
from you bent over here a long time
every time I come here I tell them yeah
I say I'm gonna get something so
different and it never is that different
but today we're gonna go a little
different my favorite color is rose bold
like no Mikey can't I don't even know if
you can see it I mean can you see it
this lens is so good very tiny little
bit sure are you guys out there just
like shut up so that's that I wasn't
actually nervous at all while I was
getting it done even though we did end
up putting some of the blush toner on it
twice because the first time we did it
didn't really show up at all moving on
do some updates about everything that's
been going on huge thank you to everyone
who tweeted me about seeing me on
Celebrity Apprentice we filmed that show
a while ago so we've kind of just all
been waiting patiently for it to come
out I had a lot of fun on set it was
pretty cool because the topic for the
celebrities was create a viral video and
here's the thing you know trying to
create a viral video out of seemingly
just thin air it's pretty difficult
especially nowadays because there's so
much content being posted on the
Internet one of the biggest
misconceptions I think a lot of like
companies and industries and people sort
of not really in this space understand
they just think that we create viral
videos every day but that's not the case
we're cultivating an audience for
creating insistent content or bringing
back the same viewers that we have every
day some of our videos do go viral and
what does that even mean it means that
someone shares your video a lot of
people share and share and share and
also people rip your video down and then
repost it and
they end up taking credit for it on
their Facebook pages or Instagram or you
do that's how you know you've got a
viral video on your hands and of course
along the way some people might not be
that into you anymore so they click on
subscribe or their unsubscribe on their
own or Mac Jenna and Edie came over to
watch the Celebrity Apprentice which was
super fun what's happening over there oh
well you see oh it's so cute we're
having a photo shoot
it's all oh wait I think we missed where
I got introduced whoops that is a cool
shot though yeah I'm just good-looking
teams
that's my firm wanna go hold it there's
absolutely nothing that this woman does
not know when you guys are creating your
videos and thinking about the video that
you guys want to watch yourself and that
you would share nice job Justine simple
instructions people know the secrets and
you having sort of that relatable moment
is something that I think does well to
virtually not like relatable very
relatable yes I hate what I get barbecue
sauce on my body that he's loving it
he's like huh he looks like this pretzel
again thank you to everyone who tweeted
it was really cool to see everybody
watching I had a really great pair of
socks this little dog is speedy boy boy
was one of my most favorite little
Internet puppies you can still follow
him on Instagram and his owner still
post cute little pictures of little
throw backs of speedy so these little
socks are like little socks that are in
the memory of him and almost hurt to cry
I cried the day that she posted a
picture and and said little speedy had
passed on it was like a shot through the
heart I remember I was in New York and I
had just landed opened up my Instagram
and but I just wanted to show you guys
he's super cute socks and go send speedy
boy boy some love say we miss you speedy
boy boy oh hey sue
he's got a little tongue always sticking
out next up I wanted to tell you guys to
go watch a video if you haven't watched
it already Josh Sundquist - I've known
for quite a long time I met him at one
of the first VidCon ever and since then
we've made a bunch of videos together
he's written a bunch of books and I feel
like it's now tradition that every time
he comes out with a new book we make a
Josh Sundquist themed cake some of you
guys might have seen it already but
we've made a bunch of cakes and put his
book inside of the cake and then just
kind of you don't put the book inside
and we're gonna preach it close it up
make sure you guys check out Josh's book
I put a link in the description love at
first sight comm is where you guys can
check out the book it definitely do it
josh is so talented he also has a bunch
of other books we should hang out
sometime just don't fall next up I had a
list I had a list of things that I
wanted to talk to you guys about gosh
where's my phone oh I can't believe I
actually had to make a list but I can't
remember anything today I am also
posting a 24 hour vlog it is 24 hours of
videos that I posted in 2016 I've been
talking about this for a while i rated
exporting issues did you guys know that
final cut only allows you to export 24
hours as soon as you hit that 24 hour
market then resets so when I was
exporting this vlog that was 33 hours
technically final cut thought that my
video was 9 hours and 30 seconds because
at the 24 hour point it still had
several other hours to go it just got
confused so in the confusion it then
only exported nine hours of 30 minutes
all with you 33 some hour video and then
I had to make sure that I kept this
video under 128 gigs and some YouTube
accounts on YouTube you can only upload
12 hours so I wasn't sure if I could
upload 24 hours but I thought hey and
when I tried anyway but just in case I'm
gonna export three separate videos
twelve twelve and however many they were
left so I pretty much filled up my
entire hard drive trying to figure out
how to make this work once I had the 24
hour video I exported it and it was too
big and then I'm freaking out to export
it I just want to let you know that it
took about 16 hours just to export the
video it then took another I feel like
half a day 16 hours to upload it it then
took another 16 to process it actually
took longer to process because once the
video processed on you
to get processed into 360p so then it
had to go a whole nother day the process
into 720p it was crazy but it was more
an experiment to see if I could do it
but here's what I want to do I want to
have a 24-hour quiz one of the goals new
features on YouTube is if you start
watching a video and you click away from
it and then you come back on the
thumbnail it'll show you how much of
that video you've watched and when you
click back to it after being gone for
however long you were gone from your
computer it'll start you back up right
where you left off so I thought it'd be
really fun I know not everyone is gonna
watch that entire video because that's a
long time and even if I want you to
watch it I'm still gonna call you crazy
for doing it I'm calling myself crazy
for even posting said video we're gonna
have fun little quiz how many a drone
videos did I make how many phones did I
break how many cakes did I bake how many
friends did I make oh I'm out of the
fifth one I don't I'm I'm not sure you
can make up your own for the fifth so
since I could only do 24 hours I had to
go through and choose which videos I was
going to remove so I decided to remove
most of the sponsored videos a few
baking videos that weren't as
entertaining as the others most of my
live streams
I also took out some Apple news videos
because I felt like those are kind of
topical and at that point watching them
now is just really it's it's pointless
do you want to see an iPhone 7 rumor
that video should be up if it's not up
already
stay tuned because it will be up very
very soon so I guess I'll see you guys
in my next video which is probably 24
hours long so basically if you're new
here you're either gonna love me or
you're gonna hate me after watching that
video so take it with a grain of salt
I'll see you guys later bye so what do
we do did you know what we're gonna do
oh yeah we're gonna make a cake that's a
lot a lot cake watch so many cakes you
gotta figure out where to cut
Dexter that looks good you did a great
job this is like the new library
[Music]